o Olá tudo bem é Matheus Jacobsen faço
parte da comissão organizadora do Sedex
USP São Carlos e hoje eu tô aqui com avó
Denise Brandão uma de nossas speaker de
nosso evento para falar um pouquinho
mais sobre urbanismo e revitalização de
espaços públicos e para gente começar
Afinal quem é mal Denise Brandão Olá São
Paulo Henrique Brandão trabalho na
Comlurb Rio de Janeiro a 12 anos faça os
trabalhos
o e são mais de 10 anos atuando como um
gari né valdenise aí como é que eu sou a
rotina que que você vive no seu dia a
dia né que você vê por aí nas suas do
Rio de Janeiro trabalho que eu faço aqui
ele é um pouco comum de se ver né um
ponto irregulares assim de pontos
críticos eles né a comunidade pessoal
vai fazendo
eu pego um espaço vazio e Vai
depositando o seu resíduo ali e quando
tirar um grande depósito e o meu
trabalho e o que que não tava valendo de
nada varredura mar com todo dia da mesma
coisa e quando voltava no dia seguinte
era a mesma quantidade dele isso para tu
retirava
Oi e aí a gente pensou no projeto uma
proposta que realizar aquela área a
gente vai te a grana né Tem de apoio daí
nós botamos a redação da manga e
começamos a pegar alguns brinquedos
quebrados pneus e ele tá ligando daquela
área é nós temos um escorrega e uma
gangorra azia e um balanço já que
estamos estamos receitinha fizemos uma
praça há mais de pudim vai amar é o
chamada batizado da Praça da Paz e muito
legal
e depois quando ela disse imobilizou
separadores para fazer um mutirão para
ajudar a gente a limpar Foi muito legal
a inauguração que as crianças Olá vai
ter aquele espaço e aí eu me encantei né
e irá olhar daquelas crianças eu
Encantada
E por que não fazer isso no todo toda da
Comunidade
E aí começamos a ver um monte deles vai
começar um grande dia olho que tiveram
os colaboradores do moradores algumas
empresa também local que vai lavar
presente
E aí começamos a fazer o número do outro
trabalho e teve um único eu conheci a
Carolina naquela precisa exemplo aqui
para mim aquela fazer a palestra e e a
gente fez uma calçada Mas tensão e
limpeza e dá uns 15 Campinas
eu quero desenho dela dava passagem para
acertar cadeirante né
e no final desse trabalho também foi
muito bom e a calçada inteira era tomada
de lei era um torno de paz toneladas de
Oi e aí os moradores começaram a se
mobilizar e gostar e agradeceu Por que
podia Abrir sua janela para poder
almoçar pelo poder ficar de molho fica
inteiro igual seu ar condicionado de
volta Como morador para mim hoje te
agradeço muito agora eu posso ligar meu
ar condicionado de novo Quanto tempo não
ligava ele ele faz muito engraçado e aí
eu vi que o retorno da comunidade era
muito maior eles precisavam um pouquinho
de atenção e um pouco de educação assim
bate boca a boca conversa e aí eles
foram mudando
e o lado da calçada que trabalhou quando
terminar de trabalhos pessoa pode
terminar o trabalho não ao final do
trabalho como pegar a outra parte da
calçada também fazer uma limpeza geral
que vai o vento leva esse isso daqui
para lá e a gente me concluem trabalho
mais interessante nós estamos lá dois
meses para esse trabalho e aí o pessoal
da calçada do lado Começou a sair
começar ajeitar suas calçadas ele vai
começar a tampar o buraco da calçar
começar a sentar na calçada Mas tem papo
os vizinhos voltaram a se comunicar está
sem falar que eu já não saiu mais dentro
de casa realmente deve ter como eu sair
pode fazer o que ela naquela de sarada
toda podre E aí no canal quando quiser
mudar e depois ir logo grão com os
moradores para mostrar para ele passa
dele como acertando sua casa vai ter a
sua casa seu ambiente e aí todo mundo
começou a cantar com a gente até as
crianças
as crianças ficaram Encantadas lá com
projeto e quando eu tava lá no
finalzinho último canteiro que eu olhei
para cima tem um tecido é uma ladeira eu
vi uma Senhorinha de se passando pela
calçada para que Ele me mostrou lutamos
tanto eu parei por um tipo de agradecer
a Deus aquilo porque ela estava no lugar
certo e com segurança na calçada andando
na sombra sem lixo sem nada para ela
poder carregar não tem preço bacana
valdenise e que eu acho que chama mais
atenção na sua história né Essa sua
capacidade de enxergar um potencial
transformador é onde ela ele não ver no
descarte ali é indevido das pessoas em
áreas indevidas e como é que começou
essa paixão sua essa sua habilidade Como
que você percebeu é que você era capaz
de chegar esse potencial a verdade é
sempre um pouco atentada né lá né
é esse que é para eu me identifico pois
eu sempre pensando como que pode fazer
aquilo ali para mudar ou não posso
melhorar o meu trabalho até hoje com
qualquer coisa que eu faço eu gosto uma
forma de fazer com que ele seja mais
leve
é e qual é aquela parte do eu falei na
varredura tava vendo que parecia que eu
tava enxugando o gelo né E aí sentamos
ontem meu gerente mas conversamos dentro
da Maré
e a Maria ele é muito dispensa né amor é
uma qualidade muito grande e ela fica
bem no meio da Avenida Brasil Ali
amarela aí bem no miolo mesmo
Oi e eu vi que dava para fazer ali
Quem era esse pequeno ela só que a minha
mobilização mesmo era Pegar e colocar
alguma coisa que tivesse vida para que
as pessoas se tivesse importância que
quer que ele mudou dica aí para mim é um
espaço que tem que ser linha tem que se
manter tem que preservar mas tinha que
fazer alguma coisa que impactar pessoa
limpar não tava dando um jeito aí
começou o Jardim começou com brinquedo E
aí quando chegou um tempo na direita O
pessoal já ia lá buscar cadê aquela dali
das plantas eu queria que ela fizesse um
jardim para mim ir na rua a gente vai
cuidar e os moradores já começaram a se
santificar mudar e aí já foi surgindo
com agora ele pede para ouvir a gente
fez mais cartão deles e sinal de Rambo e
também do lixo pallet controles para
cima deles
O que é um poucas caçamba chegar uma
louco evento gente eu tô como que vai
ser o mega evento aquilo que pagamos o
mundo via Copacabana mas esse Landim
Ramos fica lotado bem evento e grande
bebendo eu chegar lá no dia seguinte
para trabalhar para ainda tá lotada
dirige pessoa e aí como que eu ia fazer
para agilizar o trabalho dos garis ali
e na areia do Piscinão e esteira e
arrastar e apesar e as caçambas caçambas
da hora isso não Bora colocar um mais
cima e aí quando chegou no ângulo
trabalho estava reduzindo não tem mais
reduziu bastante queijo Drogaria e
ligaria longe lá então olha só para
trocar o saco né
e ficou bem mais leve
e você comentou né valdenise era a
questão que você ia lá limpava Rua
limpava aquela área e no outro dia tava
mesma coisa É como é que você vem
importância dessa atuação da população
da comunidade local esse tipo de projeto
e até mesmo a gente pode chamar de
intervenção né como você vê essa
importante Qual o papel da comunidade
ali objetivo agora meu objetivo eu fico
vendo aquela quantidade de lixo em poder
reciclagem tem uma outra a minha perna
né é infelizmente me dá um toque então
isso ele tem uma riqueza imensa e eu
penso no futuro eu quero fazer Aquela
quantidade que vai para o oceano console
e desses tijolos mas eu já disse
o e educação ambiental educação
ambiental é o que tem que ser para ontem
a gente pensa no projeto também chegar
dentro da escola começando pelas coisas
amarelas também de ser disposição me
engano e fazer uma educação ambiental
com as crianças que começar com ele é
bem melhor né E eles mesmo pode passar
mensagem para os mais velhos quando a
criança deixa de fazer umas 10 já fica
meio que inibida né meu filho não tá
fazendo tem que ser o exemplo né não vou
fazer e E aí pegar ele tem a merendeira
dele fica o lanche dele e pegar o lixo
orgânico dele e fazer uma composteira
dentro das escolas e uma horta uma
pequena horta ensinar eles a reciclar
até na aula de educação ambiental e
transformar a Terra Viva e a planta
terra dele ele usar não consigo dar
vacina nele
e você comentou né valdenise ela questão
que você ia lá limpava Rua limpava
aquela área e no outro dia tava mesma
coisa É como é que você vem importância
dessa atuação da população da comunidade
local esse tipo de projeto e até mesmo a
gente pode chamar de intervenção né como
você vê essa importante Qual o papel da
comunidade ali o importante é os
moradores é Goiás essas idéias né E como
foi dito lá né tomar como se você
extensão da sua casa mesmo que a
extensão da sua casa né que ele abre a
porta e Aquela quantidade de lixo né a
varanda dele né
bom e o que posta que os moradores
Comprei essa ideia gente faz a gente
precisa deles para isso para manter essa
história sílabas e se eles não eles não
entrarem dentro do projeto penso do que
tá acontecendo na comunidade fica na rua
dele para o bem dele porque alguém da
Saúde da população mesmo
e eu acho que os moradores tem que
tentar 100% WhatsApp não a gente perde
todo o foco Mas eles graças a Deus até
agora ele tem cuidado eles até abrigam
Se alguém for jogar sacola de lixo lá é
o final e não vai para outro lugar aqui
a menina veio aqui Já ajeitou sem rosto
já outro lugar e aí eu quero que eu falo
então desafiado a gente buscar outro
lugar que tem o número daí Janeiro e
levar esse pouco de amor que a gente dá
eu eu tenho como amor que ajudar né amor
é para gente finalizando já né Valdene
já agradecendo primeiramente né que que
você faça um pouquinho seus planos
futuros seus projetos futuros e deixar
sua mensagem final né que você gostaria
que as pessoas é ouvissem aqui levassem
adiante baseado muito na sua ideia no
seu projeto em toda essa missão linda
que você vem criando e desenvolvendo as
suas do Rio de Janeiro e quem sabe vão
atingir todas as suas do Brasil né não
futuro eu preciso que os moradores apoie
essa ideia eles não joguem lixo não
desgaste lugar errado existe uma coleta
de ar aquele pos que essa informação ele
nos ajudem a na coleta aqui e todo o
trabalho da conduta e da coleta
varredura é esse projeto conhecia hoje
eu trabalho no projeto de revitalização
de Praças e ele coloca brinquedos
immobiliaris e são tem por cento
recicláveis
o projeto legal ainda é
e a mensagem que eu tenho para dar bom o
futuro que eu quero aí você continuar
ele me manda esse pode fazer vários
Jardins pelo Rio de Janeiro tirar toda
aquela imagem ruim feia sabe é uma
cidade maravilhosa chega um canto da
cidade e joga joga de lado ninguém quer
olhar para aquele lugar né e acha que
não tem vida em Vida em vir todos nós
precisamos de vida de boa qualidade a
gente precisa domínio saneamento básico
Spazio é só isso que a gente precisa de
um pouco de atenção do pouco de carinho
e as pessoas vão lá e que é importante
para aquele pessoal e não tem tanta não
tem tanta coisa né Bia
e eu pretendo continuar fazendo como se
fosse um incêndio na floresta que o
beija-flor Vai lá então aí eu tô a busca
do elefante com a tromba para poder vir
e ajudar a pagar esse resultado e assim
trabalha uma corrente do bem
é bacana e agora é só resta agradecer a
você né valdenise Por todo seu empenho
em toda a sua participação aqui trazendo
que a gente é busca no te der né que são
ideias que merecem ser compartilhados e
tenha certeza que a sua merece e muito e
é isso pessoal Obrigadão e valdenise é